nawet autoafirmacja jako silnego kraju
więc nie chwytaj, tylko zniszcz nasze
będzie w porządku z krajem
widzieć siebie tak silnych, jakimi jesteśmy
możemy to tam po prostu zabrać i tam zniszczyć
kilka wiosek w kilka minut
[muzyka]
Jestem wolontariuszem od 14 roku
z przodu korzystałem z dronów właściciela
przerwa między 15 rokiem a
W 22 roku nie został wypełniony, jeśli
nasza ziemia jest pełna odpoczynku
bardzo piękne, a strzelanie dronami jest świetne
piękna możesz
Istnieje takie hobby, jak fotografia Aero jest możliwa
powiedzieć, że jestem tam również jego zwolennikiem
okazało się, że moje usługi są wyjątkowe
na żądanie wojska Cóż, na szczęście w
zasady Zdecydowaliśmy się na wiele, wiele
zadania z pomocą tych dronów zrobimy
rozwiązywać
pewna wiedza w tej dziedzinie I Ale nadal
Mam to i trochę to zrobiłem, to wszystko
rzeczy w kompleksie bardzo mnie przywróciły
szybka inteligencja dosłownie w pierwszym
w czasie wojny poskładałem wszystko, co miałem
Przygotowywałem się, rozumiem, że wojna może
zacząć
teraz całe życie jako armia opiera się na
drony to po pierwsze oczy wojny, po drugie -
nadal jest to element wstrząsowy
przede wszystkim jest to wykrycie wroga
musisz zobaczyć, co się na tym stanie
stronie, aby wiedzieć, które właściwie
działania, które powinniśmy podjąć, gdzie strzelać z artylerii
jak umieścić swoje pozycje odwrotu
zaliczka i tak dalej
inteligencja zdecydowała realistycznie i
zadania humanitarne polega na tym, że my
na przykład nie wiedzieli, co się dzieje
przez naszych uchodźców po tej stronie, tj
faktycznie był jeden humanitarny
korytarz wzdłuż tego nasypu jest inny
korytarz humanitarny tam na tym moście
na tym nasypie
dowiedzieliśmy się, że jest tam problem
woda podniosła się i nie mogą tak po prostu
dokonali tam normalnego przejścia
improwizowana tratwa, na której można
na przykład krzyżować jedną leżącą osobę
albo wszyscy inni muszą iść w ten sposób
woda, a potem była temperatura
temperatura wody jest gdzieś między 3-4,5
co z tego, że nie każdy może to zrobić i tak właśnie jest
z tego powodu był pewien, że tak powiem, pewny
taki problem z przyprawami, byśmy jakbyśmy
Oczywiście producent jest tam za pośrednictwem mediacji
Czerwony Krzyż został znaleziony tutaj bez przeziębienia
taka mała łódka o wadze 70 kg i
po prostu rzucił, że mogą chociaż
przejść z My jakoś tak mało
cywilizowany przynajmniej ten proces
o ile można to uspołecznić
wszystkie sytuacje
[muzyka]
mamy też inne informacje na temat
coś zniszczonego w kim, czyli cóż
elementarni ludzie Może tam wiedzą
nawet chcesz wiedzieć w jakim stanie
ich dom
istnieją różne rodzaje dronów są złożone w
Zarządzanie jest proste, to znaczy dla niektórych
proste drony w zasadzie na moje
perswazja jest po prostu ostrożna
i zrównoważony operator, który potrafi:
rozwiązać już pewne zadania do wykonania
niezwykle przydatny z przodu
to część naszej pracy, co ty
jeśli używasz cywilnego drona, musisz
wystarczy zaakceptować bycie przed tym
gotowy, że zostaniesz zastrzelony, ponieważ
cylinder A jest widoczny z punktu widzenia
znalezienie operatora, a byłby daleko od tego
leci To znaczy, jesteś cały czas zmuszany Ot
ugryź wroga i tych kilku
nawet setki metrów, aby
byłeś kilka metrów dalej i umarłeś
gdzie jesteś zainteresowany
temu
ostrzał moździerzowy
optymalizacja armaty jest częścią pracy
obecnego operatora, mam nadzieję, że jednak
po miesiącu to się jakoś zmienia my
zdobędziemy wystarczająco dużo dronów
standard wojskowy
drogi wojskowe Oczywiście to już inna historia
możesz przylecieć z daleka
niezauważalny dla wroga, ale dla mnie
drony wojskowe nadal są tutaj osobiście
Nie widziałem rąk od półtora miesiąca wojny
nie trzymał
[muzyka]
dla mnie wygrana oznaczałaby
demilitaryzacja Rosji
to znaczy, aby nie było prawdziwego wroga
możemy
to będzie zwycięstwo, czyli rozumiem, czym one są
teoretycznie możemy to osiągnąć
nawet opuścił Ukrainę
ale marzenie Rosji o tym, co nie pozostanie
nigdy nie zostaniemy zniszczeni, dlatego myślę, że
konieczne będzie osiągnięcie takiego parytetu
możliwości wojskowe Kiedy to będzie?
gwarantowane
[muzyka]
jeśli chcesz pomóc Ukraińcowi
proszę o wysyłanie zwycięstw na Ukrainę
drony wojskowe lub pomoc
pieniądze przez fundusze charytatywne i to
Chwała Ukrainie naprawdę nam pomoże